identical twins are as close as nature
can get to human cloning tiny replicas
with identical genes wonders of human
reproduction some are amazing mirror
images their movements perfectly in sync
others can be separated for years only
to discover they share strikingly
similar jobs tastes and hobbies
but not all identical twins are as
identical as we once thought advances in
genetic science are revealing key
differences in personality development
disease even sexuality
through state-of-the-art 4d ultrasound
scans scientifically accurate visual
effects and microscopy footage we delve
into the complex a delicate world of
twins in the womb this rapidly
multiplying collection of cells is
called a blastocyst and it's here that
nature's most remarkable reproductive
anomaly can sometimes occur it's an
event so mysterious
it wasn't witnessed until recently
several days after conception the
blastocyst spontaneously splits into
each new blastocyst is composed of cells
with identical sets of chromosomes and
they carry the same arrangement of genes
along their length the two blastocysts
now have the potential to develop into
identical twins
fifteen weeks into their journey from
conception to birth the identical twins
move for the first time
they interact and explore their
environment with their hands and feet
touching and even appearing to kiss
eventually their mother will feel the
same kicks each twin feels in utero
sometimes they appear aggressive other
times almost caring they look identical
but unseen influences may already be
taking effect ones that could subtly
alter the expression of genes in their
growing bodies and new research claims
these subtle changes to a genes
expression can be passed down through
generations without affecting the
underlying DNA researchers studying a
register of births and deaths in a
remote region of northern Sweden noticed
a peculiar phenomenon a generation of
boys who experienced a famine had
grandchildren who led longer lives
on the other hand descendants of the
boys who enjoyed plentiful food as
children experienced an increased risk
of diabetes cardiovascular disease and
higher mortality rates the effect of
famine was especially strong if the boy
was just about to start producing
reproductive cells his sperm
it seems the genetic makeup of these
reproductive cells were directly albeit
subtly altered by the famine or feast
through their sperm they passed on a
nutritional legacy to future generations
the more we explore the hidden world of
epigenetics the more it seems we are not
simply a product of our genes it's 35
weeks
the twins are now fully developed
they have hair eyelashes nails and can
open and close their eyes and mouths
conditions in the womb are cramped even
though at four-and-a-half pounds each
weighs a third less than the average
baby our twins are ready to be born at
week 35 by c-section it's not always
obvious to the obstetrician whether the
twins are identical or fraternal but our
twins share the placenta the clearest
indication that they're identical
after an extraordinary journey our to
reproductive marbles have made it safely
into the world they may look alike but
we know they're already different